الدكتوره
سياسيه المانيه ام ارهابيه قياديه في
تنظيم مواطن الرايخ لم يدور في خلد احد
تساق القاضيه والقياديه في حزب البديل
اليمني المتطرف والنائبه السابقه في
البرلمان الالماني البستان الى تحقيق
بتهمه هي الاخطر على الاطلاق تدفعها قبضات
من رجال قوات خاصه للمكافحه الارهاب وهي
التي قالت عنها وزيره العدل في حكومه
برلين انها جابت على تقديم الادعاءات
الكاذبه واهانه اللاجئين والتقليل من
شانههم
وفقا للنتائج التي توصلنا اليها فان
التنظيم لديه مجلس يقود حكومه لديها
ادارات ووزارات مختلفه مثل مجلس الوزراء
الحكوميه
ثلاثه الاف من قوات مكافحه الارهابي شنو
عمليه امنيه هي الاكبر في تاريخ المانيا
المعاصره شملت 11 ولايه ونفذ خلالها 150
عملياتهم اسفرت عن توقيف العشرات ومصادره
مواد واسلحه فهم يواجهون تنظيما اعلن عزمه
اسقاط الدوله الدستوريه بقوه السلاح روسيا
الحاضره في قلب التنظيم وفق الروايه
الرسميه تطولها اتهامات بربط اتصالات مع
قياده المجموعه
الحديثه هنا على وجه التحديد يدور عن
الاتصالات الروسيه مع سليل اسره النبي
حاول التواصل مع المسؤولين الروس من جهوده
لتنصيب نفسه رئيسا جديدا للدوله تخص
الشرعيين تصنع
الروسيه على بلادنا كانت جميع الانشطه
الروسيه تحت رقابه سلطاتنا الامنيه
الحكومه الالمانيه وصفت التحقيقات الجاريه
بانها ترفع الغطاء عن هاويه تهديد ارهابي
وقالت ان الخليه المفككه كانت مدفوعه
باوهام الاطاحه العنيفه
والاديولوجيه التاموريه
لا يعترفون بالمانيا الحالي
يعتبرون انفسهم امتدادا لحقبه الرايق
الثالث قبل انهيار النازيه ويصرون على ان
حدود المانيا تمتد الى اعزاء من هولندا
وفرنسا ولا يخون سعيهم لخوض الكفاح المسلح
من اجل اسقاط النظام المستشار الشعب
طيب الجزيره برلين